ان كنت اقعدونا ولا تجيبوا لي الميه ويجوا
لعندي
ولا وعد
راحوا كل يوم راح ولاده
كلمات قليله قد لا تختزل حجم معاناه هذه
السيده التي وجدت نفسها بين ليله وضحاها
وحيده بعدما خسرت من كانوا يسندون ظهرها
ويعيلونها على عاديات الزمان
لحظه لم تتجاوز الدقيقه كانت كافيه لتجعل
هذه السيده تعيش ماساه حقيقيه اصابه
ابنيها ووفاه احفادها حتى منزلها لم يتبقى
منه سوى الانقاض التي جلست تبكي عليها
حسره وحزنا على قساوه المقاله اولادي
مستعجل ببنت قاعدين ما شفت
مقعدوني قالوا لي البنيه البيولاتك
اجيت من التراب قدامي
[ضحك]
زلزال ذهب بخمسه من احفادها وادى الى
اصابات بليغه بابنها
واحد مكسور ظهره واعد مكسوره رقبته
[موسيقى]
يروح يبدا يتفرج دار اولادي
السيده ترفض مغادره المكان فاين لها ان
تذهب ومن عاشت لاجلهم لسنوات التهمهم
الزلزال والدمار
اشوف دوري قبل ما يشيلوه كل امنيتها الان
ايجاد جفاميل المفقودين تحت الانقاض
والقاء نظره وداع اخيرا لن تواسيها حجم
الماساه وسامه ذهبي العربيه